hello everyone I'm Bob Roberts they were
at the president of the University of
Ottawa Heart Institute and director of
the Canadian cardiovascular genetics
Center I'm a cardiologist but my area to
search for the last two decades has been
genetics of heart disease today I'm
talking about genetics of coronary
artery disease and just to be certain
everyone knows what that means we're
talking about the atherosclerosis that
builds up in the coronary arteries but
it could also include that when a
platforms on the top of that it causes a
heart attack and so you can substitute
we're referring to one or both of these
processes when we talk about genes
related to it I have declared a couple
of conflicts although has nothing to do
with what I'm going to say today but I
do do consulting work for Cumberland
Pharmaceuticals and celeriac Corporation
one of the reasons that we are
interested and have been interested for
some time in genetics of coronary artery
disease is of course for the application
of personalized medicine personalized
medicine by definition refers to the
treatment customized on the basis of
one's individual genetic variants now
one can of course obtain that
information by measuring the DNA
sequence directly or they can measure
expression of that DNA through its
protein whether it's in the blood any
other fluids such as saliva blood or
urine or tissue I think it's important
to keep in mind that today we all
recognize that all human disease results
from an interaction between genetic
variants and the environment
and whether you have broken a leg the
healing of that fracture will in part
depend on your genes and how they
interact with the specific other things
done in your environment how did we get
to where we are just briefly what it
counts for a lot of this variation in
the human yes it's true that the human
genus originated probably more than 6
million years ago but modern humans are
felt to be probably about 200 thousand
years old and they moved out of Africa
somewhere between 120,000 and 150,000
years ago where does the variation come
in your human DNA
I think everyone probably is not used to
thinking of it this way but your DNA is
turned over every few days and
reconstituted terribly accurately with
only one error being about one base per
billion that it makes however and even
then there are other things that try to
correct that defect
despite this low error rate it does lead
to a mutation rate of about 1 times 10
to the minus 8 which gives you about 40
new mutations per individual per
generation so in a human population
today where we have 7 billion currently
there are about 400 billion new
mutations in the current generation now
many of these of course are
insignificant but it's good to keep in
mind that 99.5% of the DNA sequence of
old humans is identical so that 1/2 of
1% is what gives all of us our
individual differences and that includes
our predisposition towards disease or
our protection against diseases
1/2 of 1% of 3 billion a DNA sequence
means that about 15 million DNA
sequences differ among humans now
fortunately for us it's even less
complicated because we now know that
about 3 million of these DNA sequences
are single nucleotide polymorphisms that
have substituted and evidence suggests
strongly today that these 3 million
DNA polymorphisms account for almost all
of human variation whether it's the
color of your ear to color your eyes or
whether you are indeed predisposed to
particular disease over the years those
mutations have those that are in fact
positive and adaptive have been
incorporated and become very common
those that are deleterious remain rare
and most cases become even more rare or
are eliminated completely so the result
is today we have about 3 million
polymorphisms that account for human
variation so that based on the data we
know about 80% of all human variation is
accounted for by these 3 million single
nucleotide polymorphisms which involve a
single nucleotide being substituted in
your DNA sequence now for the past 20
years genetics has had a golden age of
looking for rare single-gene disorders
of which over 3500 genes have now been
identified these are rare disorders that
occur in less than 1% of population most
of them occur in less than 1/10 of 1% of
the population
what we are now interested in of course
are common diseases 20 common diseases
account for 89% of all the deaths
the world but until a few years ago the
technology was not available to pursue
genes related to those common polygenic
disorders which I will be talking about
today we've known from epidemiology
studies that about 50 percent of
susceptibility to something like
coronary artery disease is genetic and
so it's that interaction between the
genetic component and the environment
component that gives you the disease
that you know I think also it's
important to keep in mind the argument
that often was used is it nature versus
nurture meaning is it genes versus
environment we no longer subscribe to
that we now know that it's the
interaction of your genetic makeup with
your environment it's the interaction
that decides the differences and what
you do not one or the other so much and
so with that introduction keep that in
mind as we go through it has been
postulated by several authors in the
recent years that heart disease coronary
artery disease heart attacks will be
eliminated in this century the rational
reason for thinking that is that we have
shown in the past three decades that
clinical trials in which we take a
particular drug and performed in a
randomized placebo-controlled manner
that 30 to 40 percent of coronary artery
disease is preventable by treating known
risk factors such as cholesterol and
blood pressure we agree I think everyone
does that if you want comprehensive
prevention of coronary disease if you
really want to markedly attenuate it or
eliminate in this century it will
require treatment of genetic risk
factors as well as these known
environmental risk factors and so this
is sort of where we're going at this
and what I shall be discussing today a
major barrier of course to that
comprehensive prevention has been you
first have to identify the genes
predisposing to the disease there have
been several problems because unlike
rare disorders such as Huntington's or
Parkinson's coronary artery disease like
diabetes and many other diseases is due
to several genes each conferring only
minimal risk our common way of isolating
genes for rare disorders was of course
to collect families of two or three
generations and using a few hundred DNA
markers we could locate those markers
that only were inherited in those
affected with the disease and then we
knew the marker was close to the
responsible gene we could move into that
area clone it and sequence and get the
mutation this is not possible with
coronary disease one cannot do it by
that approach instead one has to use the
approach of lost case control
Association study which led to what's
now known as genome-wide Association
studies this is very simple you
basically collect thousands of cases
thousands of controls and you run
literally hundreds of thousands of DNA
markers in cases and control and any
marker that is statistically
significantly more common in your cases
and controls would be considered to be
in the region of a risk DNA region or
risk genetic variant for that disease
and so the barrier is being having
enough large enough sample size the
other was of course having microarrays
that had hundreds of thousands of DNA
markers
and platform that could run them easily
and that first microwave became
available in 2005 Affymetrix subsequent
to that Illumina and there are others
available today made it possible to
perform the first genome-wide
Association study in which on that array
there was indeed started out with
500,000 markers then it went to a
million markers and the problem why you
needed large sample sizes is because if
you accept the p-value of 0.05 as
statistically significant but since you
are taking 1 million looks you had to
divide that 1 million into 0.05 which
meant you had to have a p-value of 5
times 10 to the minus 8 you had to have
8 zeros in front of it and that's why I
require the large sample size we were
fortunate in 2007 here at the Heart
Institute and simultaneously the group
at Iceland we located the first gene or
genetic variant for coronary artery
disease which is on chromosome 9 on the
small arm which is now known as 9 p21
that was published in science 2007 at
the same time the Icelandic group also
in the same issue of science at the same
region and agreed with our story from
that point of view so 9 p21 was the
first genetic risk factor for coronary
artery disease and heart attacks but
there was a significant surprise in
store for us 9 p21 is very common we
expected that it occurs in 75 percent of
the population it is a risk allele that
today is estimated to occur in about 4.5
billion people it is not a risk factor
from what we can see in African or
African Americans but the rest of the
world Chinese Korean Japanese all of the
East Asians South Asians
Oh M 9 P 21 with a similar frequency and
if they have two copies is about a forty
to fifty percent increased risk for
heart disease if you have one copy about
20 or 25% the real certain surprise of
that study was that 9 p21 locus is
independent of known risk factors for
coronary disease namely it doesn't act
through cholesterol or blood pressure or
diabetes it is acting through as of this
time some unknown mechanism whereby it
mediates increased risk for coronary
disease that was certainly an
interesting and significant finding
because it told us other things are
going on to cause heart disease it isn't
just cholesterol or blood pressure
recognising that we needed large sample
sizes and in 1921 we add genotyped a
total of 23 thousand individuals here in
Ottawa in Texas in Denmark and we
recognized that these variants and only
a small amount of risk associated with
them and in order to discover all of
them or most of them it would require an
even larger sample size and from that we
put together a large international
consortium now called cardiogram which
involved both Oxford Cambridge Leicester
and initially in Germany with also
included University of Pennsylvania
Harvard University University of Texas
along with Stanford and ourselves and
since that others have added this is
certainly one of the largest
undertakings in the history of
Cardiology and we leveraged our
resources probably up to the level of
about two hundred and fifty million
dollars all of us
pursuing genes related to coronary
artery disease
today our initial discovery sample size
is now a hundred and ninety four
thousand cases and controllers which
gives us sensitivity to detect most we
think common variance if they occur in
the population of five percent or
greater and so from that we identified
many new genetic risk variants that have
since been published mainly in Nature
Genetics today to summarize there are
now 50 genetic variants for C ad that
are optional wide significance meaning
that their original discoveries
associated with a p-value of 5 times 10
to the minus 8 and they have all been
replicated in independent populations we
feel the chances that one of these
variants not being a genetic risk is
probably less than one in two million so
with 50 genetic risk variants I'm not
going to go through this table but what
you look at here is 15 of them are
acting through no mechanisms you can see
here several acting through cholesterol
or HDL or triglycerides and that four
are acting to hypertension and one is
acting through formation of thrombosis
and time to cause heart attacks the
other is surprised and in this table how
did the 50 genetic risk variants 35 of
them are acting through mechanisms other
than our known conventional risk factors
we do not yet know through what
mechanism they exist but clearly this is
an important story from a research point
of view the fact that most of these
genetic risk variants are mediating
their risk for atherosclerosis and heart
attacks through mechanisms at this
moment we do not know and clearly this
is a great impetus for future research
and I think it's fair to recognize that
the next five to ten years will be very
important in trying to understand how
these risk factors are mediating their
risk we can say a few things about them
each genetic risk variant exerts minimal
risk on the average about 17 percent
increase relative risk they're very
common 50 of the 50 percent of the
variants occur in more than 50% of
population and about 30% occur in more
than 75 percent of the population so our
original hypothesis that common variants
predispose to disease has been proven
these are clearly very common one other
unfortunate for us is that over 80% of
the genetic risk variants are located in
non protein coding regions which means
they are not in a gene that's coding for
protein but are regulating those genes
that do code for protein our phenotype
and what we do clearly is determined by
the protein and so most of these genes
that are regulating where that protein
will be turned on or off or what have
you this also makes it even more
difficult to understand the function of
how they were most of our world with us
in cell culture or animal models we are
expressing a protein and looking at its
function it's important to keep in mind
that all of these variants at the moment
are identified by a single nucleotide
polymorphism in that region we do not
know what the exact mutation is all we
know is in that region it could be
hundreds or even thousands of base pairs
away from the snip is that
a DNA region that predisposes to disease
one interesting feature that we did find
if you look at the table of 50 genes for
coronary disease only one of them
directly relates to or is associated
with myocardial infarction per se it's
been recognized by epidemiologist
probably for three or four decades that
if you're a blood group A or B you have
an increased chance of having a heart
attack and that what we found in this
study that in fact blood group A or B or
a B increase the risk for heart attack
by about 20 percent
we found that blood group O is not
associated with any increased risk for
coronary artery disease or myocardial
infarction furthermore the rationale has
become clear the locus for the [ __ ] blood
groups they they encode for proteins
called transferases
these transferase transfer a
carbohydrate moiety to von Willebrand's
factor and that prolongs the half-life
of von willebrand factor von
Willebrand's factor is crucial in the
plotting and formation of flåm BOCES so
with a longer half-life they're more
vulnerable to thrombosis they're more
vulnerable to form a clot in the
coronary artery which precipitates a
heart attack on the other end the o gene
it encodes for a transfer AIDS protein
but probably about a hundred thousand
years ago it was mutated and the protein
it makes is no longer functional so no
carbohydrate moiety is transferred and
von Willebrand's factor retains its
normal lifespan and so there's no
increased risk of a heart attack if you
have blood group O
we've all it's also being shown by
others now that the plasma levels of von
Willebrand's factor our 25% higher in
individuals with blood group a or b as
opposed to old and other studies have
shown that if overall if you have blood
group B you have 11 percent increase if
you have both a and B 20 percent so I
think it clearly indicates the mechanism
for this this does have therapeutic
implications to the future people who
have a heart attack people who have
bypass surgery people who have
angioplasty with stents in order to
prevent clotting in the future we may
have to think about do we change our
therapy do these people have to take
aspirin or other blood thinners to
decrease their chances of clotting when
you have foreign particles or if you
have bypass surgery at the moment
nothing is official but it certainly has
implications for what might happen in
the future
looking at the 50 genetic variants we've
also learned something in this table
what you see is the cases in green and
the controls in blue every one as
several of these common genetic variants
but the cases and controls don't
separate until you get a certain number
above that here the average person is 17
once you get beyond that you start to
see an increased incidence of the
disease in green indicating it's not
whether you have one or two it's how
many you have it's the total burden from
all of these common variants that carry
a small amount of increased risk and so
this concept I think is well accepted
and well-established now based on the
data that we had
so to go on to say where are we and what
are we trying to do at the moment
obviously a great certainly the major
goal will be
understand one how these systems work
with respect to the 35 genetic risk
variants that we have and do not know
what their mechanism is one approach to
this is sort of captured in this
statement here from nature saying show
me your friends and I'll know who you
are and by that I'll explain to you is
developing molecular pathways we some
people call systems biology and so if we
could identify molecular pathways to
which these independent genetic risk
factors mediate their risk it would
certainly give us an important clue
about how they do it and what they do
it's claimed I think with some
reasonable scientific accuracy that at
any one moment or second in time in a
single cell there's about a hundred and
thirty thousand interactions between
proteins computers feel accurately that
they have catalogued many of those which
is referred to as the human interactome
and at the moment there are over 33,000
unique ones protein to protein
interactions that have been identified
by various means using that computerized
data one then goes on to form various
interactions with the hope that we could
trap some of our genes in those networks
which would give us an idea at what's
going on so far in looking at the
network analysis we have had some
interesting results three of the
pathways carrying some of the genes are
involved in information and three of the
genetic variants that we've identified
shown on this slide one of them as you
can see is interleukin 6
are involved in those bit of bollocks
pathways we've strongly indicate that
inflammation is one of the means whereby
some of these particular risk bearings
mediate their risk when you put this
together what you're looking at here
inside the big circle is the normal
pathway for synthesizing cholesterol
then outside of the circle you had the
Interlochen stat and you had PDF which
is platelet derived growth factor those
genes have been shown to increase the
risk of coronary disease and they
mediate in different ways inflammation
but also what you see here that both
cholesterol and these other genes
interact true Kappa beta to have certain
effects on both the inflammatory pathway
as well as cholesterol so I think the
data is highly suggestive at this moment
that information is part of the pathway
which certainly people have postulated
for decades and this seems to be in
keeping and supportive of the concept we
know that atherosclerosis develops as a
result of an inflammatory process in
part mediated by cholesterol and now I
think you can see these genetic variants
predisposed for greater information in
these pathways and so we are expecting
that in the next five to ten years
information will be shown to be not as
powerful perhaps as cholesterol but one
of the significant pathways for
atherosclerosis and heart attacks what
are some of the things we've learned so
far to summarize them one in addition to
cholesterol and conventional risk
factors we know no there are other
factors contributing to the cause of
coronary disease
I think the evidence is coming on strong
that information is one of the
fundamental contributors to coronary
atherosclerosis we have clearly shown
that blood group a and B but not blood
group O increases the risk of having a
heart attack
by at least 20% I won't go in today but
already a new therapy for cholesterol
and ever inhibiting pcsk9 as emerged
this is a genetic variant that works
through lipids normally pcsk9 removes
the cholesterol the LDL cholesterol
receptor from the linings of the blood
vessels and because of that the
cholesterol stays around longer and his
associate increased incidence of heart
disease if you give an antibody to an
ibid pcsk9 you can remove LDL and this
was clued by the fact that in families
who had lost function due to mutations
in pcsk9 gene they're at a much lower
LDL cholesterol and their chances of
developing heart disease was several
fold less this resulted in the new
therapy which is now in its been already
tried out as an antibody for injection
once a month in clinical trials phase
two and is now undergoing phase three
looks very effective and in addition to
statins which is a routine therapy can
now further lower your LDL cholesterol
and your risk of heart disease so this
is another that is emerged in the
genetics obviously there is tremendous
potential today for development of new
diagnostic biomarkers new therapeutic
targets as illustrated by pcsk9 and I
think as we pursue the mechanisms of
these independent genetic risk variants
a more comprehensive pathogenesis of
coronary artery disease and heart
attacks is unfolding
what are the advantages of genetic
variants over that of measuring your
cholesterol or what have you
well clearly it doesn't vary with time
it doesn't vary with meals drugs or
gender it can be determined by a single
blood tests and it means that you only
need to get one blood sample per
lifetime since one's DNA does not change
over one's lifetime
now the two things that ultimately will
be we hope applied using this new
information of genetic variants one
would be risk stratification picking up
the disease early for early prevention I
won't say much about that the other is
targets to develop novel therapy at the
present time you look at 9 P 21 it is a
potent risk factor it's just as potent
as being a current smoker or increasing
your LDL by 33 milligrams per deciliter
or increasing your blood pressure by 10
millimeters at the present time these
ages are not incorporated in a routine
practice of cardiology but clearly
they're for that purpose ultimately as
we learn more about them will be
utilized as part of the management but
at the moment it is still on a research
basis part of the reason we're all
concerned and eager and enthusiastic and
excited is because such genetic
information will be much more available
in the very near future it costs
probably half a billion dollars to
sequence the complete human genome of
craig Venter when is was done in 2007
because of changes today sequencing the
rate of sequencing has increased more
than ten thousandfold
the cost of sequencing DNA has decreased
1 million fold this means that in the
very near future while only about 10,000
individuals at the moment have had their
whole genome sequence we think it's a
conservative estimate that millions will
have their whole genome sequence by 2017
and certainly in the 20s it could very
well be a routine the implication being
all of these genetic risk variants that
I talked about for coronary disease of
course and other diseases similar
advances have been made and today over
1,700 genetic risk variants involving
more than 60 diseases have been
discovered and have been published and
one thing to keep in mind is how will
your physician or anyone else really
handle all of this data and how to
interpret it but it's unlikely that it
won't happen and so physicians will have
to get educated and be ready to make
this change and it is a daunting task
and there are other issues at stake if
we look at what has happened with data
explosion it's estimated that if you
looked at all of the information
available whether it's on television
whether it's in libraries or books or
what-have-you
that it would amount to about five
exabytes of data between the dawn of
written history and 2000 today five
exabytes between 2003 to 2010 we created
pride exabytes
every two days today we are creating
every 10 minutes the amount of data that
was available from the dawn of history
until 2000 of course most of it is spam
but it still has to be sorted given all
of this then but DNA sequencing having
increased ten thousandfold but
ability to store retrieve and analyze
that data has improved only 16 fold so I
think it's fair to say as we look at the
future the convergence of two
technologies routine genome sequencing
and how to store retrieve and analyze
this data will be a major challenge for
personalized medicine and also for
research in general most of what I've
talked about is in a recent review that
was published earlier this year in
Journal of American College of
Cardiology called genomics and
cardiovascular disease if you'd like to
follow up on some of this
in addition given the tremendous impetus
to really educate and to bring us into
the 21st century
what has started to form now is the
various societies and specialties in
medicine have gotten together to try and
make something of this and prepare for
the necessary education to do this and
this is called the intersociety
Coordinating Committee for genomic
physician education I chair one of the
workshops utilizing the tools for
education as a representative American
College of Cardiology but as you can see
on this slide
most of the specialties in medicine we
had our first face-to-face meeting in
January in Dallas we have another one
coming up in September and we're working
on how to put some of this together so
it will be possible for physicians and
allied physician professions different
fields nurses you name it technicians to
try and put together packages that will
help in their particular field to get
ready for the onslaught of this
information I would also like to thank
cardiogram plus c4d and all the
investigators who certainly were
involved in identifying the genes that
we have shown today and these are some
of the people who work here at the
Institute who make it possible in my
laboratory
now I forgot to indicate to you that
while we're doing this you can put
together questions and that shortly I'll
go to Question and Answer and try to
answer some of these questions if in
fact they are there so I'll see if there
are any there at the moment there are no
questions available for display at the
moment if indeed this can be corrected
I'll be happy to do so I see one
question now is your lecture transcript
available or our tour slides available
for review and my after that is yes they
are available and you can get them
through the people who are putting this
together so I hope that you got my
answer they are saying it is available
and certainly you can get all the slides
and review it through the webinar people
I don't see any other questions so with
no other questions I will all they're
saying here
so I thank you very much for listening
and I hope that this will be helpful and
I enjoy doing it thank you very much